hey um hello everybody today we are
going to be summoning Cthulhu
okay that's our plan right let's go
[Music]
Oh are we just kidding right into it cuz
I wasn't ready for this I barely I
barely got here hey hon I haven't even
done my hair yet I'm all out of style
oh yeah I look like ass oh yeah oh hell
yeah that's the style I was going for
garbage hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to cards of
Cthulhu the game where you are either
trying to beat Cthulhu or you're trying
to beat everyone who's against Cthulhu
or you're beating Cthulhu's competition
not that he has any
I don't really know you're on a bike you
got a gun and then I think there's some
squiggly monster in the distance oh I
like the sound of sacrificial I'm not
even gonna read what these cards do I'm
just gonna do based on what my gut
feeling tells me Oh
stunner burn set the gun to burn oh god
what am i do hi oh okay oh yes burn
surprised bag revenge ultra kill where's
Cthulhu had no idea that would be going
on a lovely Sunday ride and is that a
chainsaw monster in the distance I
believe that's a tall lanky chainsaw
monster anyway link Lee leech or tik-tok
I like leech they balance the power and
speed of your cards oh hey oh you got a
you got a mouse belly voodoo ski
poink yay ultra kill I don't know what
the hell that means
some cards are counter-attacks of other
ones alrighty then
yeah leech I guess I didn't have any
damage done I should probably do that
afterwards oh jeez ow ow ow
alrighty then well that felt good use
your cards efficiently I don't know if I
can oh hello
why do you have one leg and boobs and
what's with the weird head things what
is all of that what the hell happened
what's with your twin weird waving arm
head dicks
I guess all off reason this time maybe I
should actually read the cards I liked
leach it healed me a bit those those
nice a gasps a freeze em first
right off the bat Oh what the hell why
are you caressing your own boobs like
that or just the one which is weirdly
swelling I think you're just trying to
contain it in your body what the [ __ ] is
happening here what kind of weird biker
gang am I in this is okay so if the
enemy's health is 10 are above deal plus
2d ok I'm sorry I've totally forgotten
about you guys here I got sidetracked by
the chainsaw mouth belly man and then
the weird grabbed my boob lady and then
the weird double [ __ ] wavy arm thing
guy it's a little bit disturbing but I'm
assuming this is all for a good cause
the good cause being either stopping
Cthulhu or summoning Cthulhu because I
haven't seen dulu yet wouldn't mind
seeing a little bit but you know beggars
can't be choosers at this point so we
just kind of got to go on our way
believe in the cult that we're in
obviously and hope for the best so
Cheers
ok venom it's gonna do venom first and
then freeze my Ultra killed you give
venom first oh hi hey friend oh no
surprise back for you [ __ ]
okay this time I'm gonna get you your
weird waving double dick lady No
ah gotcha oh those heal both it said oh
god there's two ladies all there's two
of them there's boob grab lady and then
this chainsaw man
alrighty then I guess I'll burn them
venom them and freeze them that sounds
pretty good
oh I can only have three in here that's
no good nice beds I guess good bye also
alright then hello I guess I gotta deal
with this on my own
okay can you stop with the chainsaw okay
we barely got through that I don't feel
too confident about anything here just
gonna burn you burn yeah yeah yeah
probably should have saved something for
the other guy revenge there was a lot of
revenge happening over there oh I get it
revenge is just toss back and forth
kinda nice I guess not for me cuz we're
gonna die stop with the chain side don't
like the chainsaw the cheese sauce is a
little much don't you think
learn the strategy of each enemy I don't
even know there's a sanity here just
kill him kill him dead
kill him hardened and in a lot just die
please little more
thank you brace no supplies bag no no
okay okay I'm dead alright thank
goodness gracious I'm dead because I
can't wrap my goddamn head around what's
going on here this is so goddamn insane
a new car disappeared in the world oh
good I'm so glad that society's
collapsed to a point where both Cthulhu
is taking over absolutely dick
everything that we got going on here and
life has turned into a perpetual battle
of card games it's like if ukyo became
real it's horrible oh my god okay I
gotta put on my theorycrafting hat
because I need to understand what
happened here
logically looking at this there's demons
right there there's demon
and they have spells so let's assume
that these cards are representative of
spells in this world so one magic reel
which I just saw dr. strange is pretty
cool so I'd like to think that brand of
magic is real but there's also like
demons and monsters and horrible things
like that so that's probably bad too but
but I'm a biker right I'm a biker by
myself finding on fighting all the
hordes literally I'm the only one
fighting I'm the only one fighting no
one is here with me fighting all of
these monsters somehow I am gifted
enough in the magical arts to be able to
beat the boob grabby monsters of this
world huh okay all right anyway I
that's enough stalling let's get back
into it oh your soul grows stronger Oh
health protects you from death yeah I
think so considering that's what life is
too late they're going for the tick tock
time bomb
oh it's boobie crabby no I lady oh no
get the fire out of there huh boo ski
well you is dead aah Oh stun seems
incredibly useful and now that I read
stun it seems like a much better one so
I can actually no to be able to stop
them I've got strategy now
[Music]
oh no actually that seems bad can you
not do that
dude I died dying is cool too okay all
right then thief freeze sounds good I
got stun and freeze if I can learn to
control the enemies and that's gonna be
better for me I suppose anyway okay so I
don't have anything else so I get out oh
that was close ow why why I'll take that
revenge thank you very much I don't know
why I'm learning the strategy about this
game because I don't think it's gonna
help me at all
can I stop that surprise bag yes yes
well okay I have no cards left I'm in a
bit of trouble here all right okay thank
you you're dead now that was no good man
I do not have enough cards here let's
see problem and color scheme okay
oh is that a new one that's new one over
there I see you I see you punchy glove
monkey tail over there I'm gonna get you
but in just a second I'm gonna get
[Music]
preparation-h
ready yeah okay man you guys think
quickly about this we get it we're gonna
do huh stop jeezum uh hi oh my God look
at you you got babes do better I gotta
see you die oh my god that was close
oh jeez I don't like this can I get
another stunt big Jesus this is actually
this is actually legitimately tough like
legitimately tough I'm gonna get another
stun because you can never have too many
stuns good golly there's three of them
oh that was a boss oh hi nice stinger oh
it's a big big
to be biggest a bitched bit no that's
right you stop that up thank you hi half
lady I had no cards if that wouldn't
mind steel bid I've got no brain to
steal there's nothing in my head anyway
all right goodbye oh okay then I'm doing
surprisingly good I'm surprised I'm not
dead but you know it is what it not God
stop shoving your giant stinger in my
face really really weird dude really
weird I gotta admit okay hello boob
grabbed lady good to see you again no
not the cards but you know if you could
just not kill me that'd be great haha
I'm not dead and you are I have no cards
left I keep coming out and I think not
well this is gonna take a while but
while we're here let me just have a nice
conversation about you while I watch you
grab and heave your booth all right can
you tell me where Cthulhu is because I'm
remind yourself that overconfidence is a
slow I know about the killing thing who
the [ __ ] are you you sheriff here you're
the sheriff and I much like you can you
just die please okay good hey it's big
dick Larry how are you doing big dick
come on no no I said no you freeze that
dick keep doing this oh [ __ ] you you
blew up my goddamn bike I don't know
what the hell is going on all I can
assume is that they are obeying the word
of Cthulhu so what I need to do is I
need to go get some goddamn answers from
Cthulhu myself because I don't have a
goddamn clue what's [ __ ] going on in
this goddamn world so I'm I'm I'll be
right back I'm gonna go get some help
I'm gonna form a coat
gonna have matching robes and we're all
gonna summon Coutu Lu and ask him what
the [ __ ] is with this goddamn game okay
so what we're doing here we need to get
some answers out of the son of a [ __ ]
known as good truth he made this game
that I played that didn't make a damn
bit of sense so we're gonna we're gonna
find him gonna bring him here so we can
ask him some gosh-darn questions right I
buy on board with this
okay recipe for summoning Cthulhu blood
ritual sacrifice Abel volunteers so I've
never done this before so I'm not
entirely sure how it's gonna go but I
imagine it's gonna be like this we're
gonna sacrifice the two volunteers
we're all gonna chant in tongues over
the pentagram of blood so don't actually
it's a public park dude and then Cthulhu
should show up somewhere maybe not here
maybe or something like that he'll he'll
show up eventually
it's a busy guy okay sacrifices come in
here all right now you feel it feel it
yeah you could okay you guys know what
to do
[Music]
oh it works holy crap okay um huh I
didn't actually think I'd get this far
yeah what was up with that game I'm just
saying like it didn't make a lot of
sense yeah I know devastation and
desolation I get that it just like there
was a weird mechanical boob lady and
they really that that's the reason yeah
it didn't yeah I know you yeah I get
that you put a lot of work into it yeah
okay all right you know what just okay
that's great
thank you never mind you can go back now
you can go they aren't you all right
everybody I'm sorry guys you're gonna
die but whatever I'm sorry anyway so
sorry we're gonna need those ropes back
yeah I guess it didn't work
no little answers for us I guess it was
a little selfish to summon a dark lure
in the under
question by beating
yeah I mean for summer yeah try you
gotta ask you got to ask yeah got a gun
I mean they say there are no stupid
questions yeah but what's the worst he's
gonna say no it can't be afraid of life
lesser few murders whatever so thank you
everybody so much for watching so thanks
again and as always see you in the next
video bye bye
[Applause]
Harry yeah we should have clean up the
water